our next speaker
i've known for
many many
many many years
and it's hard to decide what i would
like to you know introduce him as
uh there's so many uh fascinating things
um aside the fact that we're twinning
today when he comes on you'll see we
have the same shirt and practically the
same glasses
right
but also perhaps this is
in his attempt to up his hipster street
cred
he started to build his own bikes
he even builds the bikes like the wheel
from scratch he told me how you do like
you the spokes are just giant screws and
you can shrew it up he gets a frame he
builds the wheels he does the whole
thing it's quite impressive how you
could build a bike i ride bikes i can't
even fix them up he's building it from
scratch which is really really awesome
so please welcome giant r nerd and bike
hipster mark
so i am going to talk to you about today
uh about basically how i use r
to manage all of uh my teaching well our
teaching because this is really joint
work with object and i'll get that in a
second but how i use r for creating
content and managing my university
course uh and doing a whole bunch of
different things and
obviously the the impetus for this this
talk is
as many as those that know me um know i
i've been teaching at georgetown and gw
for several years in the data science
program at georgetown and the master of
the science of business analytics at gw
i've been teaching a big data class for
several years and now i'm teaching more
so more recently i've been teaching a
database class but um so i'm going to
share with you what i've done again i'm
mark weisman uh i am a cloud solutions
architect at microsoft our nerd is jared
said
uh meetup founder data community dc
founder and just uh all around uh kind
of data geek
so what i'm going to show you today
is i'm going to show you a little bit
about using sharingan i know other other
speakers i've seen some of the other
slides today and many people are using
sharingan i'm going to go into a little
bit more detail just because
i'll just share with you the the the
tips and tricks that i've learned around
along the way to to make kind of nice
really um
slides same thing here is i'll be
showing you about the sharing it or
sharing it or sharing it i'm not really
sure how to pronounce it um sharing in
themer and sharing in extra packages
i'm going to show you how we build the
course website with distill
and then i'm going to touch on these two
other packages a little bit because
these are packages that we've either
looked at or used or are looking into to
incorporating into our workflow so
a package called exams and a package
called uh jh gh class which is really a
wrapper around the github api for for
doing a lot of rubric stuff and then
i'll talk about some of the challenges
that i've found along the way
what's the inspiration well like i said
as a as a as someone who's been teaching
now for a while i'm always trying to
become a better teacher and i always i'm
always trying to have
good materials you know i want i want
slides that are clean i want slides that
are easy to understand i want slides
that are easy to maintain
uh long gone are the days of doing
massive powerpoint slides or at least i
i haven't built i have to build them for
work
because i work at microsoft and um i
wish i could do more stuff with like
something like this when i'm at work but
i've been uh i've been tinkering with
some of the many packages for doing
slides over the years so uh beamer like
i started with r suite a long time ago
and try to build beam or presentations
and that you know just writing latex is
just a real pain in the butt uh you know
toyed around with markdown with to build
some of the i think not reveal there are
some of the other web frameworks but
anyway
i've been using sharon for about two
three years now uh i really like it and
also also like you know some of the
things that we see out there from the
our studio community uh excellent
educators so folks like garrick adam
bowie i think are pronouncing his name
right um allison hill uh monet and jenny
bryan you know these these are folks
that really publish a lot of great
material and i've drawn a lot of
inspiration from from these materials
and so you know again just trying to
incorporate best practices or what i
think are best practices into my
teaching
so i'm going to start with sharing it
um so obviously right so why sharing it
so we know sharingan is a package that
was written by yui uh and basically it
takes our mark down and it converts it
into really beautiful i think it's
reveal i'm not remember the underlying
uh javascript framework but you know it
allows you to incorporate code and stuff
like that but
why sharing it right because it really i
think it renders beautiful slides of
course using modern web technologies
using css using kind of the modern web
stack you can combine code and output i
mean we know that right from our
markdown um it's code based so version
controllable so again like i said i i
really don't want to get into
maintaining
uh slides that much so i want to try to
have something that i can just manage
and maintain and not necessarily rebuild
from scratch uh why sharing it because
it's web-based you can host it within a
website it's easy to display again using
a browser you don't you know you can
just display using a browser you need a
server but that's a whole other thing
you might need somewhere to host it or
you can actually even run them locally
um
the thing is uh why the way i use it is
i really want to use it in building
modular content so i'll get to that in a
second but one of the things that um the
personally i like about using sharingan
is that it really forces me to think
about the content and the layout of the
things that i want to show you know
rather than just like doing drag and
drop and just throwing everything to a
slide and have a slide that really is
not
um
it's just not pretty or it has a lot of
material like it really forces you to
sort of stop and think
um and then you know we don't need to
leave r and i always like to reference
jared's old talk of like you know r for
everything where you can do everything
from within rn and as we go along it
seems that we can do a lot more with our
these days so obviously we're all our
lovers here so i don't need to tell you
that um some of the challenges though so
as long you know as much as it has it's
good things it also has it's not its
drawbacks but there are definitely
challenges so the first one is there is
a learning curve so if you've just
written plain markdown
um that in and of itself is not a big
deal it's just kind of how do you
incorporate the there's a syntax with
the three dashes and like the difference
in sort of things and just kind of how
to get everything controlled but
the other thing is even though you don't
really need to know css uh for display
it really helps if you do just because
you can obviously tweak it
um
going back to like forcing you to to
think about what you want to show the
the one of the challenges is any sort of
graphic that you want to put into your
slides
uh you need to have an advance right so
it's not like a powerpoint where you can
draw a circle or draw a square so you
can't really you can't i mean i there
might be some javascript tools that
allow you to like draw on demand but you
know besides the point i have to go and
think through what i want to show so if
i'm doing screenshots i have to go get
the screenshot save it as a png or gif
or jpeg or whatever um and then like
just have the graphics in advance and as
i'm thinking of building the
presentation i'm you know of course
adding more material to my images folder
no wysiwyg right so obviously you're
writing code and you kind of go into
this right render right right or right
render until you get it right um sizing
the draft graphics can be a little bit
tricky um you know with experience you
can figure out like you kind of know the
size of the graphics that you want to
show and embed in the slides
um and then like it can be really slow
for me writing a nice set of slides it
takes a long time and i really struggle
with getting content from my head onto
paper not nothing new particularly but
you know as i'm doing things i pull in
images i'm only doing sorts of things so
those are the things you know these are
these are my thoughts um and you know
please i'm happy to hear comments or
thoughts if you've been using sharing
and kind of what you find good and bad
so obviously you know like everything in
r the defaults are actually pretty good
so when you build a slide with the
defaults this is what you get right this
is the this is when you start a um
you you go to our studio and you open up
a new art markdown slide and you just
you choose the the sharingan template
this is what you get you know you get a
slide
looks good you know it's pretty it's
kind of black and white this is just the
default template that our studio does
for you so
i i don't love it you know i want to
make this prettier my man of pretty is
the right word i just want to change it
so uh what i do right is
i use sharing in themer and sharing an
extra and i'm going to show you how i
actually do that
so basically this is what my lecture
template looks like right now um so i'm
going to go through these are just
sample slides so this is the title slide
uh you see the blue background i chose
the colors i like looking at the color
wheel so i try to use complementary
colors and that sort of thing and a
different font and sort of things like
that but
this is kind of the headings you know
level one little two level three four
that's uh italic text and and then the
highlighted text is in uh kind of a
magenta and then that's the same slide
but with inverse colors right so when
you use the inverse class you get the
inverse background where you can define
what that is again how did i get this i
use um both
sharingan
themer to create the theme
and sharing an extra actually i'll show
you what sharing an extra does but
here's a little bit more about the
slides so
other things that we use in these slides
are incorporating tables so uh using
cable uh ka
it's part of the knitter package so just
rendering uh tables into html so they
look nice but then one of the things
that we use which is really really cool
especially for our data visualization
class and like i said before um i don't
know if abhijit's on but abj does gupta
who also started the our meetup group
with me many many a long time many many
uh a decade ago if not more um he he and
i are co-teaching this class so we do a
lot of the development together and we
what we do is we actually teach the
class in both our python so we we focus
on sort of the theoretical aspects and
and the how i'm sorry the what and then
the how we do it in both an r and python
so we do a lot of slides that look like
this we we show a slide and we we show
something here you know how to do
something in r and then using the panels
right which you get from uh sharing an
extra so you can show you can show
similar code that does the same type of
thing uh within a panel and it makes it
really really easy to show the
difference you're not showing them side
by side but at least you can switch and
talk about the
the intricacies of either language the
other thing that we use a lot um
is just do something like this so we
have something where you know this is uh
this is a unit square data frame that i
built it's just some random numbers
between zero and and one um and then you
know here's a bunch of ggplot code and
then what happens is actually the output
on the right shown over here all right
so we so this is just part of the
template that we use so a lot of the
functionality you see here i'm going to
highlight a couple of things you see how
when i hover over the code there's a
little triangle on the left hand side
and the actual code changes color that's
provided by sharing an extra it's uh i
don't remember the exact function but
this is really useful because rather
than like selecting or something you can
just kind of hover over and highlight a
piece of code uh in a dynamic sense
and then panels are also provided by
sharing an extra so the ability to be
able to do this
okay
um
all right let me move on to the next
slide so this is what sharing in extra
does for you so it gives you a lot of
functionality if you look at the repo uh
it's not on crayon i think you still
have to install it with uh on github but
it basically it's a lot of wrappers
around advanced css functionality um
like i said you don't have to know css
but if you do it makes a lot easier but
uh garrett has written these packages
both sharing and themer and sharing an
extra
uh and what we use right is the panels
and oh tachyon so we also use tachyon's
tachyons as like advanced css which is
coded with like a dot command i don't
have examples to show you but that's the
other things that we use for for this
um so how do i jump so as you see over
here right there's actually three themes
in the slide deck the first one is the
theme of the slide that you're showing
so the black background with the purple
the second is the theme that's inside
this default and then the third is the
theme of my of of our of our template so
each of these was created with a
different theme how do we create theme
or how do you create the theme so it's
really easy you use library sharing and
themer and then you can use either
pre-built themes and then overwrite some
defaults so the one i'm showing you here
today is this one right here what i did
is i ran the code this actually outputs
i created out file called artgov2021.css
and the thing is once you generate a css
file you can use it over and over again
you don't have to have the sharing and
theme or code in your presentations
every single time you can all you need
to do is create the css once and then
use it over and over again and i'll talk
about that in a second
uh this is the theme right so on the
right hand side you see the yaml header
for the file so this is the the yaml
header for this slide deck i'm showing
right now um as you see here here's my
css which i generated before and then
i'll get into other things i use other
non-defaults and i'll explain what those
are in just a second
okay
um
so strategy for building slides like i
said i really want to focus on building
modular content
um because i don't want to have a he you
know when you start writing these really
extensive when you have
30 40 50 you know even like 60 70 slides
it can be a real pain to manage so the
way the strategy
uh that we've adopted and i've been
using this now for quite some time i
found a blog post i have a link to it
and at the end that shows you how to do
this and i just found this phenomenal so
what i do is i actually write the slides
in a modular approach so i write kind of
blocks of slides by topic and then so if
one lecture i'm going to have multiple
topics i have a top level slide a top
level rmd which calls child rmd files
over here so basically this is what the
code would look like right so here this
would be the yaml header for the top
level and then what happens is all i
would need to do semester this semester
right is just change the yaml header or
something along those lines i don't have
to go back and edit you know or find
anything here so the way this works is
you have a top let's call it a top level
r d
and then you run this r chunk when you
say r child equals uh you know topic one
dot rmd topic two rmd i found this to be
really really useful um and helps you
actually organize your your content in a
much better way
um all right so this is kind of around
sharingan i have some additional
thoughts about that later but those are
kind of the things so create your own
theme
use modular content and you know as as
you do this you have to kind of
understand the
the uh the tricks of incorporating
images whether you're going to use an
html image source or you're going to use
uh the
the knitter command which i always
forget what it is because i rarely use
it
um all right for distill so one thing is
making the content for for the slice for
the lectures the second thing is uh
hosting is now we at georgetown we use
canvas um an lms at uh gw we use
blackboard another lms
um what i've done and i kind of see this
being done elsewhere is is many
instructors just create a website uh so
this poses a couple of different
challenges one is you need to have the
content in the lms but you also want to
have the content separately so managing
content on both sides can be kind of a
pain but anyway how do we generate the
website so let me show you this um so we
use distill so distill is a uh
i guess the still is a is a framework
for scientific uh publishing um and it's
it's a form that somebody created i
don't know who created it but again
using modern web stack
it's clean it's uh it renders easily uh
and then you can use a lot of helping
functions so you can use that you know
our dis or the still package for r
leverages the distill framework if
that's what it's called to build a
website and the defaults are actually
pretty nice so what i'm going to show
you here
is um
again what is this still i i just got
this from the distil website over here
but then this is what our website for
the course looks like so this was
actually generated this is hosted on
netlify
you could either do this hosting this on
github pages or netlify we chose netlify
because
you can't really host the distill
github pages is static rendering and
this is static rendering too but it it's
it's a lot more flexible so we're
hosting the website on netlify uh with
this still but you know as you can see
you get kind of a
i i don't want to be a web developer
like i just i just don't i just want to
do something that looks good that's
accessible that's easy to navigate and
that sort of thing so we have the
calendar we have the syllabus right and
then here like when we go to the slides
you click on on a given week we probably
want to do a better job of maybe not
calling it week by week but something
along those lines so you know here you
see the slides for the for our class and
this is all hosted on the website
um so how do you start with a building a
distilled shell library distill create
website my website and so on and so
forth so it's pretty easy that gives you
the scaffolding for building the website
um so how do you create the navigation
so you have to have the underscore site
yaml file for the website where so this
is what our navigation looks like uh we
have the the left nav bar over here
we've got the uh the menu stuff over
here the only drawback to this is we
actually have to edit it every time we
add new content we actually have to go
in and edit the site yaml which is can
be a little confusing sometimes we add a
slide and we forget to add the link so
you know we are at week 4 13 and we we
didn't do that so we actually have to go
back and do that the content is there
it's just it's not linked
um how do i bring it all together so we
created a structure a repo all this goes
into repo in a github repo so the what
the way we we design it is that the repo
itself is private uh but because we're
using natlify right you you can actually
host if you need a premium account if
you're gonna use github pages
to do github uh you know to host a file
with good github pages and that will fi
your your repo can still be private the
website obviously is going to be hosted
and shown
but the way we designed it is we have
you know this is a repo for the class so
we've got admin here we have our roster
or a bunch of other things that we need
to have
quiz bank this is where we use a package
called our exams to generate some
questions that we upload into canvas for
the online quizzes
slides is where we actually
this is sort of our current architecture
this has had many iterations
but um
and then obviously the readme which is
the readme repo uh the site yaml and
then the index so this is the site yaml
for
the website this is the index rmd for
the website so the index rmd is at this
top level directory when you render the
website everything we you know
everything gets actually rendered in the
public website directory but the index
rmd has to be over here obviously any
rmd files related to the website itself
within the slides directory right this
is what we do so we create a slice
directory like lecture one lecture two
and so on and then we have a directory
called format um
again not sure if this is the best way
to approach this because within each
slides directory uh i'm sorry within
this within the this
upper level directory we have a format
directory in that format directory we
you see it's at the same uh level
hierarchy as the lecture lecture uh
directories we have out the output yaml
uh we have a bunch of setup options rmd
and a bunch and css of anything um i'll
get into that in a second in the lecture
directory we have a subdirectory for
data uh if there are any data files that
we're reading in a subdirectory for
image if we have any images that we're
reading in so obviously like with the
lectures sort of self-contained but you
could have you know still top level our
markdown and a child level are markdown
um so for the setup options uh we so
what we do here is in in this directory
so as you see here in the lecture
directory what i do is i create a sim
link to the output yaml in the format
directory that way all of my slides have
the same format and i don't have to copy
over that output yaml file because if i
change it if i copy it over and i change
it i have to change it everywhere this
way i i don't know i don't know if
there's a better way of doing this uh
i'm sure there is but the way we've done
it is we just have the formatting in the
format directory so everything is sim
linked to that format directory so if
something changes in the formatting
allah and we you have to rebuild the
slides obviously but um everything you
know it it picks it up
uh these are some of the setup options
in the rmd again the way i treat this is
i treat this as a child so in every
sharing and top level i read the setup
options here i have some some things
i've learned to use along the way like
the knitter options and some of the
different options we render a lot of
html and javascript content for things
like d3
and that sort of thing so uh abhijit
found out what we need these html
tools.preserve.ra not sure what it does
but it needs to be there to work and the
other thing i do here is i read in all
my different packages
um this is the output yaml so what i
normally do is we do um
we do this we do self contain equals
true the reason for that is because that
generates a single html file for the
output now those can get really big if
you have a lot of that's kind of the
drawback as those can get really big and
it could cause some issues with your
github repo um i do the incremental i we
don't use the incremental slides to
change the slide number or like the 16.9
ratio and that sort of thing
so that's kind of how we create the
content uh for for the website and for
the slides
uh github we use github for the
assignments so for github right we use
so what we've been using is we use a
github classroom and github classroom is
basically an automation platform on top
of github that allows instructors to
create an assignment and then students
accept the assignment and what that does
is it creates a copy of the assignment
using uh a source repo it sets all the
permissions so you can do that via
github classroom through the website uh
like over here um but you can also do
that with gh class and we're actually
starting to investigate the use of gh
class because it's within r and we can
call the github api
over there but uh you know why do we use
github classroom because uh you know
that's you need to know version control
like you just have to
and it shows a real world workflow it's
easy to use you know we can use pull uh
pull requests we don't really use those
because the grades actually go in the
lms so as you see we're trying to manage
a bunch of different platforms
separately
um exams so this is a package that
allows you to create using markdown
files or um
or latex you can actually write
questions that you can then import in
this is a specific format it's called
qti but then you can that's kind of a
standard format and then you can import
those questions into the lms so we can
write the questions just using r and and
latex and uh or our markdown and then
load the questions up into canvas it's a
little bit time consuming because you
have to understand the syntax um but
again we want to version control these
things like we were interested in
leverage this because at the end of the
day these are all text files
all right future work and challenges so
there's a lot here to manage a lot of
our workflow is is manual so we actually
have to generate the website it's all in
the same directory the same repo we have
to generate this website
in one set of files we have to generate
the slides in another set of files so
we're thinking through ways to like
fully automate this where once you like
say you create an rmd file or you need
it or every time you every time you knit
the website it picks up new content like
there's all these sorts of things that
you need to do we have to add the links
to the site yaml
um you know that's the kind of thing
that we want to do i would love to
integrate this with the lms uh that's
really not up to me that's up to the
school so the school needs to give us
api access to the lms which
probably is not going to happen
um
and then you know figure out the best
kind of structure for the repo
especially because we have all this
modular content what happens is when
you're trying to render files with
sharing in and you've got content in one
place and images in another place and
then you have a website hosted it it
just you have all these
reference these
the when the html is rendered i think it
uses a relative links so if you have
things all over the place it your stuff
doesn't render right so we need to find
a way to do this in an easier way
uh here i kind of have a bunch of useful
resources these are all of the blog
posts that i use to learn a lot of what
i showed to you today um it's great
content so there's garrick's website
there's monet's website which is linked
over before uh there's allison hill's uh
introduction to sharingan which is
amazing um and then again i'll i will
post the slides on github and i will
send out i'll share the link with jared
folks i hope to see you next year
in new york and in dc
um
[Music]
i think all of you know that i'm jewish
so in judaism right at the end of the
major holidays there is a blessing that
says next year in jerusalem well i'm
kind of saying the same thing here like
next year either in new york or in dc so
thank you very much